FEMALE VOICE: The following
content is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Today, we're going to learn a
rather powerful technique,
called the technique of partial
fractions, that's
particularly applicable for one
special type of integrand.
In particular, it's going to be
applicable to the situation
where the integral has the form,
the quotient, of two
polynomials.
In other words, suppose we have
integral ''P of x' dx'
over 'Q of x', where 'P'
and 'Q' are both
polynomials in 'x'.
And, by the way, for reasons
that will become apparent
later, we'll assume that the
degree of 'P' is less than the
degree of 'Q'.
In other words, that the
highest exponent in the
numerator is less than the
denominator.
By the way, if that's not the
case, we can always carry out
long division first and carry
out enough terms until we get
a term in which this is
the particular case.
You see, I'll make that clearer
as we go along.
But, for the time being, all we
really care about in terms
of outlining this form--
and, again, as we will often
do in these types of
techniques--
the place that we'll pick up
the real fine computational
points are in the exercises.
We'll use the lectures to just
outline what the technique is
and how its used.
But suppose, now, that we
have the quotient of two
polynomials and we want
to integrate it.
Now, the idea is this, there are
two key steps that dictate
this particular method.
The first thing is, we saw it
in the last lecture, that we
can handle denominators if they
involve nothing worse
than linear and quadratic
polynomials.
In other words, we know how to
integrate something like
'dx/x' plus a constant.
We know now how to integrate 'dx
/ ''ax squared' plus 'bx'
plus 'c'', so we know how
to handle that type, OK?
And the second important
thing--
and I'll amplify this,
too, as we go along--
the second important thing is
that, theoretically, every
real polynomial can be factored
into linear and
quadratic terms.
Now, this is a little bit
misleading, if you try to read
more into this than what
it really says.
It doesn't mean that we can
always find a factorization
quite simply.
In other words, we may,
at best, be able to
approximate a root.
We'll have to use things like
we've talked about in the
notes so far: Newton's method,
and things like this, linear
approximations, tangential
approximations.
We may have to approximate
the roots.
But that, theoretically, if
a polynomial with real
coefficients has degree greater
than 2, it has, at
least, one real root.
In other words, we can keep
factoring things out this way.
The only thing we can't do is to
guarantee that, once we get
down to a quadratic, that we can
get real roots out of this
particular thing.
In fact, the classic example
is to visualize 'x
squared plus 1'.
In other words, we can't factor
'x squared plus 1'
unless we introduce
non-real numbers.
Remember the technique you can
write, that 'x squared plus 1'
is 'x squared' minus 'i squared'
where 'i' is the
square root of minus 1.
And this factors into 'x plus
i' times 'x minus i', et
cetera, but these are
non-real numbers.
In other words, you can't always
factor a quadratic to
get real numbers.
In fact, if you recall the
quadratic formula of this:
square root of 'b squared' minus
'4 ac', if 'b squared'
is less than '4 ac', what's
inside the square root sign is
negative, and that leads
to non-real roots.
So, you see, we can't
always factor
quadratics into real factors.
By the way, don't identify
things that were difficult to
factor with things that
can't be factored.
You know, a lot of times, we
think of, say-- here's an
example I thought you might
enjoy seeing here--
take, for example, ''x'
to the fourth plus 1'.
That looks something like it
belongs to the family 'x
squared plus 1'.
And 'x squared plus 1'
can't be factored.
You might think that
''x' to the fourth
plus 1' can't be factored.
Now, again, it's not important
that you understand what made
me think of these tricks
or what have you.
What I do want to show is that
even situations where the
polynomials might look like a
known factor, they really do.
For example, with ''x' to the
fourth plus 1', we can write
this in the disguised form ''x
squared plus 1' squared', see?
That's, what? ''x' to
the fourth plus 1'.
But there's a middle term here
of 2 'x squared', so I
subtract off the
2 'x squared'.
Now, this has the form, the
sum and difference of 2
squares, namely, ''x squared
plus 1' squared' and, also,
the square root of 2
times 'x squared'.
In other words, I can write this
as this plus the square
root of 2 times 'x' times
this minus the square
root of '2 times x'.
Observing, that even though
the square root of 2 is an
irrational number, it is,
nonetheless, a real number.
The important point that I want
to point out, though, as
far as setting up this technique
called partial
fractions, is that, whether
it's easy or not easy, the
fact remains that, when we
have a polynomial in our
denominator, it can always be
factored into a combination of
linear and quadratic factors
using real numbers.
Well, it's difficult to factor
some of these things, so, by
way of illustration,
let me pick out
one that comes factored.
Let me start with a particular
problem here.
Let's take the integral 'dx/
''x minus 1' times 'x
squared plus 1''.
So, what is the integrand
in this case?
It's 1/ ''x minus 1' times
'x squared plus 1''.
Now, the idea is this.
See, here's a quadratic factor,
here's a linear factor.
What fractions do I have
to add to wind up with
something like this?
Well, again-- and this is going
to be another example of
our old adage that it's easier
to scramble an egg than to
unscramble one.
You see, given two fractions,
it's one thing
to find their sum.
Given the sum, it's quite
another thing,
computationally, to find what
fractions you had to add to
get that sum.
The idea is this.
If you wind up with a
denominator that has an 'x
minus 1' term and an 'x squared
plus 1' term, it
appears that you must have
started with terms, say, what?
In other words, you must have
had one term which had a
denominator of 'x minus 1' and a
term which had a denominator
of 'x squared plus 1'.
Because, you see, if I start
with these kind of
denominators when I
cross-multiply and put things
over a common denominator, I
will wind up with 'x minus 1'
times 'x squared plus 1'.
The question that comes up is
what shall our numerators be?
And here's the main reason why
we picked the degree of the
numerator to be less than the
degree of the denominator.
Notice, for example, in this
particular case, the numerator
has degree 0, namely, the
highest power of 'x' to the
peers is the 'x'
to the 0 term.
On the other hand, the
denominator has degree 3.
See, there's an 'x cubed'
term in the denominator.
You see, if they're doing
'x' to the fourth in the
numerator, I could have
multiplied out the
denominator, divided it into the
numerator, and just kept
carrying out the division long
enough until I wound up with a
remainder which was less than
a degree, less than a cubic.
In other words, less
than a third
degree polynomial remainder.
That's not the point.
The point is that as long as the
degree of the numerator is
less than the degree of the
denominator, it means that the
terms that we're adding must
have the degree of the
numerator less than the degree
of the denominator.
See, it's like adding
fractions.
If you start with one fraction
whose numerator is greater
than the denominator then,
certainly, any sum that you
get is going to be
bigger than 1.
In other words, if you want to
wind-up, dealing with positive
numbers, and you want to wind-up
with a fraction which
is less than 1, it stands to
reason that all of the
fractions that you're adding
must be less than 1.
So, if I'm going to wind-up
adding quotients of
polynomials to get a sum in
which the degree of the
numerator is less than the
degree of the denominator, it
means that every one of the
terms in my sum must have this
particular property.
In other words, with this as
a hint, I say look at, my
denominator here is 'x minus
1', that's degree one.
That means my numerator can't
be greater than degree 0.
But degree 0 means a constant.
So I say OK, that means that
this has to form some constant
over 'x minus 1'.
Now, I look at this
denominator.
It's quadratic.
And I say to myself I'm starting
out with a quadratic,
the degree of the numerator
can't be greater than the
degree of the denominator.
Since the degree of the
denominator is 2, that means
the degree of the numerator
can't be more than 1.
And the most general first
degree polynomial has the
form, what?
Some constant times 'x'
plus a constant.
So what I'm saying is,
OK, to wind-up with
something of the form--
well, to wind-up with 1/ ''x
minus 1' times 'x squared plus
1'', I had better start with
something of the form 'A/ 'x
minus 1'' plus ''Bx plus C' over
'x squared plus 1'' where
'A', 'B', and 'C'
are constants.
The key point is that if we
weren't sure that the degree
of the numerator were less
than the degree of the
denominator, we would
not know where
to stop in our numerator.
In other words, by this
convention, we're sure that
the degree of the numerator in
any one of these terms can't
be greater than the degree
of the corresponding
denominator, you see?
And by the way, notice, for
example, if it turns out that
we put too much in--
for example, suppose it turns
out that this numerator here
should only be a constant--
there's no law against having
'B' turn out to be 0.
By the way, again, what these
things are called--
just to increase our
vocabulary--
what I'm going to do now
is called the method of
undetermined coefficients.
You see, what I know is that I
must have the form 'A over 'x
minus 1' plus ''Bx plus C'
over 'x squared plus 1''.
What I don't know is,
specifically, how to choose
the values of 'A',
'B', and 'C'.
And the technique works
something like this.
What we do is we put this over
a common denominator.
What will the common
denominator be?
It'll be 'x minus 1' times
'x squared plus 1'.
How will I put this over
a common denominator?
It'll be 'A' times 'x squared
plus 1', plus 'Bx plus C'
times 'x minus 1'.
Now, this is supposed
to be an identity.
Now, if two fractions are
identical and the denominators
are the same, which is what they
will be after I put this
over a common denominator, the
only way they can be identical
is for the numerators
to be identical.
So, you see, what I'm going to
do is to cross-multiply here
to obtain the numerator of
the right-hand side.
And I will equate that to the
numerator on the left-hand
side, which is 1.
All right.
Now, what is the numerator
on the right-hand side?
It's 'A' times 'x squared
plus 1', that's 'A x
squared plus A'.
Then it's going to be 'x minus
1' times 'Bx plus C'.
That's going to be 'B x squared'
minus 'Bx plus C'
times 'x minus C'.
And now the idea something like
this, and I'll come back
to this in a few moments to
hammer this home from a
different point of view.
What is the coefficient of 'x
squared' on the right-hand
side of the equation?
The coefficient of 'x squared'
on the right-hand side of the
equation is 'A plus B'.
What is the coefficient of 'x
squared' on the left-hand side
of the equation?
And at first glance you say
there is no 'x squared' on the
left-hand side of
the equation.
What that means, of course, is
that the coefficient of 'x
squared' on the left-hand side
of the equation is 0.
So what we say is OK, the
coefficients of 'x squared'
must match up, therefore,
'A plus B', which is a
coefficient of 'x squared' on
the right-hand side, must
equal 0, which is the
coefficient of 'x squared' on
the left-hand side.
In a similar way, the
coefficient of 'x' is 'C minus
B' on the right-hand side.
The coefficient of 'x' on
the left-hand side is 0.
Consequently, 'C minus
B' must be 0.
And, finally, the constant term
on the right-hand side is
given by 'A minus C'.
On the left-hand side, the
right-hand term is 1.
Consequently, 'A minus
C' must equal 1.
What do I wind-up with?
Three equations with
three unknowns.
Well, there are a number of ways
of handling these things.
The easiest one I see, off-hand,
is I notice if I add
the first two equations, I
wind-up with 'A plus C' is 0.
Knowing that 'A plus C' is 0
and, also, that 'A minus C' is
1, it's easy for me to conclude
that 'A' must be 1/2
and 'C' must be minus 1/2.
And, by the way, now knowing
what 'A' and 'C' are, I can
use either of these two
equations to determine 'B',
and 'B' turns out
to be minus 1/2.
In other words, what
does this tell me?
It tells me that if I replace
'A' here by 1/2, and 'B' and
'C' each by minus 1/2, the
right-hand side here will be
an identity for the left-hand
side, that there'll be two
different ways of naming
the same number for
each value of 'x'.
In fact, doing this now out in
more detail, what we've really
shown here, in other words, if
I replace 'A' by 1/2 and 'B'
and 'C' each by minus 1/2, then
I factor the 1/2 out.
What I've shown is that one over
the quantity 'x minus 1'
times 'x squared plus 1' is
equal to 1/2 times the
quantity '1 over 'x minus 1''
minus the quantity ''x plus 1'
over 'x squared plus 1''.
By the way, I can separate this
into two terms, each of
which has a denominator
of 'x squared plus
1', and I get, what?
1/2 times 1/ 'x minus 1' minus
1/ ''2 times x'/ 'x squared
plus 1'' minus 1/2 times '1/
'x squared plus 1''.
Now, the key is this.
I didn't really want this,
what I wanted was, what?
This was to be my integrand.
What I wanted was to integrate
this with respect to 'x'.
Well, if given this identity
over here, the integral of
'dx'/ ''x minus 1' times 'x
squared plus 1'', recalling
that the integral of a sum is
a sum of the integrals, et
cetera, can now be
written as, what?
It's 1/2 integral 'dx'/ 'x minus
1' minus 1/2 integral
'x'/ 'x squared plus 1' times
'dx' minus 1/2 integral 1/ 'x
squared plus 1' times 'dx'.
Now, here's the point.
Notice that every one of my
denominators, now, is either
linear or quadratic.
In fact, without going through
the details here again, if I
let 'u' equal 'x minus 1' in
this example, this reduces
this to the form 'du/u',
in other words, a ''u
to the n' du' form.
If I let 'u' equal 'x squared
plus 1' over here, if 'u' is
'x squared plus 1', notice
that 'du' is '2 xdx'.
So my numerator becomes a
constant multiple of 'du' and,
again, I have a ''u of
the n' du' form.
And finally, if I look at my
last integral here, notice
that this is the sum of two
squares, which suggests the
circular trigonometric functions
that we were talking
about last time.
Or, if you wish, you can
go to tables and look
these things up.
They're all in there.
But, again, without going
through the details because
this is the easy part, again,
it turns out that once you
have this relationship here we
can integrate this to obtain
log absolute value
'x minus 1'.
The integral here is log,
natural log, absolute value of
'x squared plus 1'.
I can leave the absolute value
signs out because 'x squared
plus 1' has to be, at
least, as big as 1.
It can't be negative.
And finally, either by
trigonometric substitution, or
by memorization, or what have
you, integral of 'dx'/ 'x
squared plus 1' is just the
inverse tangent of 'x'.
In other words, by using partial
fractions and reducing
a complicated polynomial
denominator into a sum of
linear and quadratic terms,
I was able, by knowing my
techniques of last time,
to integrate the given
expression.
And, by the way, I would be a
little remiss at the stage of
the game if I did not take the
time to, once again, reinforce
a very important concept, and
that is it may be difficult,
starting with this,
to get this.
What should not be difficult is,
starting with this, to be
able to differentiate it and
show that you wind-up with 1/
''x minus 1' times 'x
squared plus 1''.
In other words, as usual, with
the inverse derivative, once
you find an answer and you
want to see whether your
answer is correct or not,
all you have to do is
differentiate the answer and see
if you get the integrand.
But, at any rate, this is how
the technique called partial
fractions works.
It works for the quotient
of two polynomials.
And to make the undetermined
coefficients technique work
right, you must assume that the
degree of the numerator is
less than the degree
of the denominator.
And, obviously, in the
exercises, I'll give you some
where the degree of the
numerator is greater than the
degree of the denominator.
And, if you don't perform long
division first, you're going
to get into trouble
trying to find the
answer to the problem.
But all I want to emphasize
here is the technique.
And, by the way, what I want to
do before I go any further,
also, is to emphasize a rather
special property of polynomial
identities.
You recall that undetermined
coefficients
hinged on the following.
And I'll pick a quadratic
to illustrate it with.
Suppose you have two quadratic
expressions in 'x' identically
equal, in other words, 'a sub-2
'x squared'' plus 'a
sub-1 x' plus 'a sub-0' was
identically equal to 'b sub-2
'x squared'' plus 'b
sub-1 x' plus 'b0'.
Notice the technique that we
used was is we said look at,
let's compare the coefficients
of 'x squared'.
Let's equate the coefficients
of 'x', and let's equate the
constant terms.
How do we know that you're
allowed to do this?
Well, let's see if we can show
that this must be the case.
For example, let's do this
without any calculus at all.
Suppose this is an identity.
If this is an identity,
it must be true for
all values of 'x'.
In particular, it must be
true when 'x' is 0.
Notice that, when 'x' is 0,
the left-hand side is 'a
sub-0', the right-hand side is
'B sub-0', and we wind-up with
'a sub-0' equals 'b sub-0'.
See, the constant
terms are equal.
Well, if 'a sub-0' equals 'b
sub-0', we can cancel 'a
sub-0' and 'b sub-0'
from this equation.
That leaves us with this
equaling this.
From this, we can factor out an
'x', and get to 'x' times
'a sub-2 x' plus 'a1' is
identical with 'x' times 'b
sub-2 x' plus 'b1'.
If 'x' is not 0, we can cancel
'x' from both sides of the
equation, and that
shows, what?
That, for any non-zero value of
'x', 'a 2x' plus 'a1' must
be identically equal to
'b 2x' plus 'b1'.
Once we have this formula
established, let's let 'x'
equal 0 in here, and
we see, what?
With 'x' equal to 0, then 'a1'
equals 'b1', in other words,
that the coefficient of 'x' on
the left-hand side equals the
coefficient of 'x' on
the right-hand side.
You can keep on this way, but
a very nice technique to use
here is a reinforcement
of something that we
talked about before.
I think it was when we
were doing implicit
differentiation, and
we talked about
identities verses equations.
You see, if this is an identity,
and what I mean by
an identity, that this--
we're not saying find
what values of 'x'
this is true for.
By an identity, we're saying
look at, these two expressions
are the same for all
values of 'x'.
They're synonyms.
And what we're saying is, if
these two things are synonyms,
their derivatives must
be synonyms.
And all we're saying is look
at, if you want to use
calculus here, differentiate
both sides of this expression.
And you wind-up with '2a sub-2
x' plus 'a1' is identically
equal to '2b sub-2
x' plus 'b1'.
Since these two things are
identical, let's equate their
derivatives again.
See, the derivative of
identities are identical, and
we wind-up with '2 a2' is
identically equal to '2 b2'
and, therefore, 'a2'
must equal 'b2'.
Knowing that 'a2' equals 'b2',
we can come back to this step
and show that 'a1'
equals 'b1'.
And now, knowing that 'a2'
equals 'b2', and 'a1' equals
'b1', we can come back to the
original equation and show
that 'a0' must equal 'b0'.
Now, you may wonder why are we
making all of this ado over
what appears to be a
very obvious thing?
And I would like to give
you a caution here.
I'd like you to beware
of something.
It's something which works very
nicely for polynomials,
but doesn't always have
to work all the time.
In fact, later, when one
studies differential
equations, this becomes a very
important concept, which later
gets the name linear dependence
and linear
independence.
We're not going to go
into that now, but
the key idea is this.
In general, knowing that 'a1 u1'
plus 'a2 u2' is equal to
'b1 u1' plus 'b2 u2', you cannot
say ah, therefore, the
coefficients of 'u1' must be
equal, and the coefficients of
'u2' must be equal.
Don't get me wrong, if 'a1'
equals 'b1', and 'a2' equals
'b2', then, certainly, 'a1 u1'
plus 'a2 u2' is equal to 'b1
u1' plus 'b2 u2'.
I'm not saying that.
What I'm saying is, conversely,
if you start,
knowing that this is true, it
does not follow that they must
match up coefficient
by coefficient, OK?
And you say well, why doesn't
it have to follow?
And I think the best
way to do that is
by means of an example.
For example, in this general
expression, let 'u1' equal
'x', and let 'u2' to be 'x/2'.
Look at the expression
'5x' plus '6 times
x/2', that's, what?
It's '5x' plus '3x' is '8x'.
Look at '3x' plus
'10 times x/2'.
That's '3x' plus '5x',
which is also '8x'.
In other words, 5 times 'x'
plus 6 times 'x/2' is
identically equal to 3 times
'x' plus 10 times 'x/2'.
Yet, you can't say, therefore,
the coefficients of 'x' must
be equal, and the coefficients
of 'x/2' must be equal.
In fact, if you said that,
you'd be saying that 5 is
equal to 3 and 6 is equal
to 10, which, of course,
is not true, OK?
So, at any rate, I just wanted
to show you here the kind of
mathematical rigor and cautions
that have to be taken
if one is going to use a
technique called partial
fractions, what the key
ingredients are.
Now, it turns out that not only
are partial fractions
important in their own right, it
also turns out that partial
fractions handles a rather
difficult type of integral:
one that uses polynomials in
'sine x' and 'cosine x'.
And the reason I wanted to
mention this was not so much
because the technique is nice.
The technique, by the
way, is in the text.
But there's something very
interesting in the text, the
way the author introduces
a topic.
And I thought that
that was worth an
aside in its own right.
In the section where this thing
appears, it says, "It
has been discovered that." The
author makes no attempt to
show logically why one would
expect that a certain thing is
going to work.
All the author says is, "It has
been discovered that." And
this tells a long story that, in
many cases, we wind up with
an integrand that we don't
know how to handle.
We make all sorts of
substitutions in the hope that
we can reduce the given
integrand to a form that we
know how to handle.
Sometimes we're successful,
sometimes we're not.
In the cases where we're not
successful, somebody, either
by clever intuition or what
have you, maybe it's just
blind luck, stumbles
across a technique
that happens to work.
And I, sort of, liked this
particular example in the text
where the author says, "It has
been discovered that,"
because, to me, it's not at
all self-evident, and yet,
it's a rather pretty result.
The result says this: suppose
you make the substitution 'z'
equals tangent 'x/2'.
Now, where do you pull this
out of the hat from?
'z' equals tangent 'x/2', that's
the ingenuity, the
experience, the luck.
But the idea is, let's suppose
that we stumbled across this
one way or the other.
If we translate this equation
into a reference triangle, we
have, what?
We'll call the angle 'x/2'.
And the tangent is 'z', so we'll
make the side opposite
'z', the side-adjacent 1.
That makes the hypotenuse
the square root
of '1 plus z squared'.
Now, watch what happens
when you do this.
See, 'z' is equal to '10x/2',
therefore, 'dz' is the
differential of '10x/2'.
Remember, the differential of
'10x', with respect to 'x', is
secant squared.
But we also, by the chain rule,
have to multiply by a
derivative of 'x/2' with
respect to 'x'.
In other words, if 'z' is
'10x/2', 'dz' is not secant
squared 'x/2', it's 1/2 'secant
squared 'x/2' dx'.
But what's 'secant
squared 'x/2''?
Let's go back and look
at our diagram.
The secant of 'x/2' is the
hypotenuse over side-adjacent.
That's the square root of '1
plus 'z squared'' over 1 and,
therefore, the square of the
secant is just '1 plus 'z
squared'' over 1, see,
'1 plus 'z squared''.
So, with the 1/2 in here, this
becomes '1 plus 'z squared''
over 2 times 'dx'.
And, consequently, if I compare
these two now, notice
that 'dx' is just twice 'dz'/
'1 plus 'z squared''.
In other words, what's
happened to 'dx'?
It's been replaced by a
differential in 'z', which
involves the quotient
of two polynomials.
So, 'dx' comes out very nicely
this way, in terms of, what?
The quotient of two
polynomials.
How about 'sine x'
and 'cosine x'?
And, again, notice the
dependency on identities.
'Sine x' is twice 'sine
'x/2' cosine 'x/2''.
But, from my reference triangle,
I can pick off the
trigonometric functions
of 'x/2' very easily.
Namely, the sine of 'x/2' is
just 'z' over the square root
of '1 plus 'z squared'', and the
cosine of 'x/2' is just 1
over the square root of
'1 plus 'z squared''.
Plugging that in here, I find
that 'sine x' is twice 'z'
over the square root of '1 plus
'z squared'' times 1 over
the square root of '1
plus 'z squared''.
Multiplying this out,
I find, what?
That 'sine x' is twice 'z', and
the square root of '1 plus
'z squared'' times itself is
just '1 plus 'z squared''.
In other words, 'sine x' is
'2z'/ '1 plus 'z squared''.
In other words, with the
substitution, what
happens to 'sine x'?
It becomes '2z'/ '1 plus 'z
squared'', which is also the
quotient of two polynomials
in 'z', OK?
Finally, how about 'cosine x'?
What identity can we use
to reduce 'cosine
x' in terms of 'x/2'?
Why do we want the 'x/2'?
Again, notice that even though
we may not have invented this
substitution by ourself,
once it's invented, the
relationship to the angle 'x/2'
becomes very apparent.
At any rate, notice the identity
that says that
'cosine 2x' is 'cosine squared
x' minus 'sine squared x'
translates into 'cosine x' is
cosine squared of half the
angle minus sine squared
of half the angle.
Well, 'cosine squared 'x/2'',
well, 'cosine 'x/2'' is just 1
over the square root of '1 plus
'c squared'', so 'cosine
squared 'x/2'' is just 1/
'1 plus 'z squared''.
Similarly, 'sine squared 'x/2''
is just 'z squared'
over '1 plus 'z squared''.
And what we find is that 'cosine
x' is '1 minus 'z
squared'' over '1 plus
'z squared''.
And, again, what's happened?
'Cosine x' is now expressable
as the quotient of two
polynomials in 'z'.
In fact, as an application of
this, let's come back to an
integrand that's been giving
us some trouble for
quite some time now.
Let's look at the integral
'secant x dx' and see if we
can't use this technique that
we've just learned to solve
this particular problem.
Notice that secant is 1 over
cosine, therefore, integral
'secant x dx' is integral
'dx' over 'cosine x'.
Now, let's come back here
for a moment just
to refresh our memories.
We saw that 'dx' was two 'dz'/
'1 plus 'z squared''.
We saw that 'cosine x' was '1
minus 'z squared'' over '1
plus 'z squared'', therefore, '1
over cosine x' will just be
the reciprocal of this.
In other words, coming back here
now, we can replace 'dx'
by '2 dz' over '1 plus 'z
squared'' and '1 over cosine
x' by '1 plus 'z squared''
over '1 minus
'z squared'', OK?
Therefore, in terms of this
substitution, integral 'secant
x dx' is just twice integral
'dz'/ '1 minus 'z squared''.
But, what is this integrand?
This integrand is the quotient
of two polynomials in 'z',
therefore, I could use partial
fractions here, write this as
a term: something over '1 plus
z' plus something over '1
minus z', et cetera, solve the
problem in terms of 'z', and
then, remembering that 'z' is
'tangent 'x/2'', I can then
replace 'z' by what its equal
to in terms of 'x', and in
that way solve the problem.
Now, you see, what I want you to
see again, that comes true
here all the time, is how we
are continually looking for
ways of reducing integrals to
equivalent integrals, but,
hopefully, ones that are more
familiar to us, meaning, what?
Ones that we are
able to handle.
In the next lesson, we're going
to find a very powerful
technique, which is far more
general than partial
fractions, a technique which is
used over, and over, again,
which is probably the single
most important technique.
But, I won't say any more
about that right now.
We'll continue with this
discussion next time.
And, until next time,
good bye.
MALE VOICE: Funding for the
publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.